dumb ways to die
so many dumb ways to die
yeah
back with the new camera new mic shaved
face ready to rate some dead people's
deaths i really appreciate all the sport
in the last video i had so much fun and
i'm glad you guys enjoyed watching him
last episode we rated the ancient greeks
mainly and it was hilarious
and i have moved up turtleman from i
think c tier to eight here because
okay so he died because an eagle dropped
the turtle in his skull he died from
baldness the turtle thought his head was
was a rock
but the best part is that there there
was a prophecy about him saying that on
that specific day you will die in a
house or a house will crumble on you or
something like that so he was all
paranoid about i better go outside
nothing can hurt me outside except
turtles falling from the sky
i just love the images they make me
happy now moving on to the
middle renaissance time baby maybe it
gets weirder i don't know uh this is
called victims of the 1580s dance plague
excuse me what this is an historical
event in the holy roman empire now wait
i thought you were talking about oh it
happened many times dance plays are a
thing we gotta watch out look at these
dudes they can't stop
what am i looking at
she's clearly not dancing
because it happened twice uh huh between
50 and 400 people took to dancing for
days and they danced to their deaths
it's called a stress-induced mass
hysteria okay whatever all right sure
uh dumb that's dumb that's dumb as hell
e very disappointed it made me laugh
though okay another uh death from
laughter this uh dude was italian who is
it all right this joke is off the hook
man there's gotta be some pickle rick
level okay let's hear this joke uh he
died from laughing too much at an
obscene joke during a meal in venice
that's it what was the joke
it was so funny no one lived to tell the
tale the ultimate joke
my god it exists
italians found the ultimate joke
f
i'm gonna have to extend the act here
soon hey i've heard about this everyone
was talking about this hans steininger
look at this dude
look at that man's beard
hell yeah
he died from his beard
he died when he broke his neck by
tripping over his own beard his beard
was 4.5 feet 1.40 meters long and was
usually kept rolled up in a leather
pouch well not today rests his soul he
died from his greatest strength the
irony i like that one i don't think
we're gonna get two beer deaths but
honestly who knows seat here
moving on to early modern period maybe
better i don't know
we have francois
vatel
this guy okay this guy was so upset
because he had a big party of 200 2 000
people and
he was so mad that the seafood was late
his delivery of seafood for the party
that he committed suicide with his sword
and his body was discovered when someone
came to tell him about the fish
ah
oh
mamma mia
sorry
it's like the shittiest sofa pro or
something it does doesn't it anyway oh
my god
blur this
blur this
uh by mati das bhai satidas by dayala i
am so sorry that happened to you i'll
bump you up to eat here i got you fam no
one should have done that to you that's
messed up okay making big leaps making
big leaps 19th century no way
john cummings he saw a knife swallower
at the circus and he was like that's
cool
i'm gonna do that they don't actually
swallow the knives right but he actually
swallowed the knives is this possible he
swallowed four knives and quickly passed
three i assume that means this might get
out of knife he later
he then swallowed 14 knives
after some days with abdominal pain you
think he passed all of them dude how big
are these knives how do you eat 40
knives and then he swallowed 20 knives
stop it stop the knives stop eating them
but after a few days he had only passed
the case this man had 20 knives in his
stomach he died after four years in pain
an autopsy found a knife blade and a
spring in his intestines and between 30
to 40 fragments of metal wood and horn
in the sun many horns as well dude if
this guy was a modern-day youtuber easy
easy five mil subs easy hundred mil john
cummings
absolute mad lad
he can't he couldn't stop hitting knives
that's some tlc [ __ ] i got
please why the heck why couldn't i live
in the 19th century god damn it the tlc
episodes would have been so much better
governor morris died from an infection
after using a whale bone to clear a
blockage in his urinary in
god dude governor morris you dumb
schmuck how big is a whale bone how big
is i don't know if i want to know how
big a whale bone is oh man stuck that up
his pee pee stop it you're a governor
you should have known better after don't
do that
[Laughter]
why am i laughing this is awful
matilda set her dress on fire while
trying to hide a cigarette from her
father oh my god matilda this is why you
listen to your parents matilda you
should have known better these are
getting a little too close to home at
this point i don't know walan dig him
accidentally shot himself
while demonstrating how the victim might
have done so
he was a lawyer and he was trying to
prove
well i mean point-proven legendary
lawyer and he died oh no
all right i like that one that's
definitely seep here
why the 19th century was weird man okay
we have rasputin the eu rasputin uh i
don't know this he
tried to be poisoned by oh felix
even looks like me younger me no he
doesn't actually so he he fed him tea
cakes and wine which had all been laced
with cyanide but
he just wasn't affected by it
bro so he was then shot in the chest and
believed to be dead but after a while he
left up and attacked felix who fred
himself and fled
rasputin followed and made into the
courtyard before being shot again
collapsing in the snow bank that's
badass rasputin i hope he wasn't like
some evil guy or something i i know he
was like meant to be evil in that movie
anastasia but he was actually sweet to
anastasia but i'm going to give him a
seat here and hopefully i don't get
cancelled was getting a little too close
in history here we'll see if i continue
frank hayes a 20 year old jockey at
elmont died of a heart attack mid-race
and collapsed on the horse which
nonetheless crossed the finish line
first
still carrying his body off frank hates
the base
so he won
oh my god
i won the race but at what cost i like
that you know what let's beat here i'll
be generous oh my god thornton jones
woke up to find that he had slit his
bro
motioning for a paper and pencil he
wrote i dreamt that i had done it i
awoke to find it true and it died 80
minutes later he had done it to himself
while unconscious great now i'm
terrified of sleep thank you thornton
jones
thank you so much that's so oh that's so
creepy no you wouldn't sleep for me you
get left here
[Music]
i'm sorry what marry reeser her body was
found by the police almost totally
cremated where she sang while the
apartment was relatively damage free
some speculate that she spontaneously
combusted i gotta be scared of that now
mar mary what do you what did she know
what happened to mary that is so weird
that is so weird i'm getting freaked out
by these
e
a
or anything oh my god oh my god it's
true it's true no it's true oh my god
they told me about this and i oh god
okay so i used to play a lot of tennis
and sometimes as a kid we would help pro
matches to catch the ball and give them
to the pros and they told us right
before i explained this before right
before we came out they were like watch
out because the guy died because the
serve from the tennis player hit the
ball people that we were the ball
collectors and the pee-pee and he died
and it's true and his name is dick he
died after a ball struck him in the
groin and he fell out of his chair dick
dick dick i am so sorry i feel such
compassion people say i'm insensitive
for making this list but i i feel such
i feel your pain i do and no one should
die like that's just messed up dick got
hit in the deck and i i don't like uh
it's nothing funny
oh god bless you bless your soul a
thousand years i feel like if i go on
i'm just gonna get cancelled even though
there's so many i'm gonna stop it here
and i'll
i'll think about it i'll think about it
but thank you for watching another
episode
of dumb ways to die if you enjoyed then
smash on that act don't forget to
subscribe
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game
use any item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there stickers
our emotions memes our emotions express
your emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this